deborah james has danced her way to
adene hood
since her cancer diagnosis she's not
wasted a moment
even after breaking the news she was
beginning end-of-life care she's raised
more than four million pounds in just
five days the royal marsden hospital is
one of the chosen beneficiaries of her
fundraising
it's been an emotional week for her
consultant who's treated deborah for
more than five years
you know i learned a lot from deborah
about about the human endeavor
about the challenges that cancer
patients face and also she came up with
a few good research ideas that we
discussed i can't go out
i'm sick
deborah james used her social media
platform bowel babe to break the taboos
of cancer her podcast you me in the big
c
propelled the deputy head teacher to
fame
her final episode was recorded after
she'd begun end of life care
i hope that anyone who's listened to the
pod who has
read one of my columns read my book or
looked on my instagram and stuff will i
suppose
if they can afford to buy me a
gin and tonic to send me on my way and
by doing so hopefully we can raise some
money for these charities
debra was speaking to her podcast
producer this week after she'd announced
she'd ended active care
when i look down i see it's deborah i'll
think wow what's this gonna be next you
know what's gonna what's the next idea
devs
and uh i'll miss her
that's what i'll miss
deborah james often dressed up to spread
the word for people to get checked
tributes so often come too late after
someone is no longer with us
for deborah james the nation has been
able to show their love and appreciation
with one of the country's highest honors
i suppose
that's it from me i can't believe it
that that is it for me
enjoy life because it is so precious
it's
all i want right now is more time and
more life
um
and i would also check your poo
sally lockwood sky news